The last area we're going to discuss in regards to memory, is what's known as
Long-term Potentiation. Long-term Potentiation is the strengthening of a
synaptic connection that happens when the synapse of one neuron repeatedly
fires and excites. Excites another neuron. Much of the work on the study on
long-term potentiation came from Hebb. Now, you should recall Hebb's law from
our lesson on the brain. Neurons that fire together, wire together. Another
researcher, Kandel, discovered that even as sea slug was able to create a
long-term memory. This was found by how the sea slug reacted to a shock. So,
what he did was administered a shock to the tail of the sea slug, and the sea
slug had a defensive response. When he did this only one time, the defensive
posture lasted about ten minutes. However, if you did this four to five times
in close succession, the sea slug had the same defensive response that lasted
for days after the shocks. Which shows the sea slug created a long term memory,
since its response lasted for days. Kandel quoted that conversion from short to
long term memory storage requires spaced repetition. This goes along with the
idea that practice makes perfect, even in snails. So, from research such as
this, we can see again the importance of neurons firing together and wiring
together, and the result that changes in our brain and our behavior. Other
research by Kandel showed how particular genes getting turned on in the nucleus
of a cell can signal neural structures to grow which is neurogenesis. But this
only happens during long term memory not during short term memory. Amazingly
what this means is that every time we learn something that's long term it's
because our brain has actually changed. So, if you remember what we're talking
about right now in this lesson, next week, that means that your brain has
officially formed new neural connections which are the basis for your memory of
this lesson. So you can officially say that your udacity psychology class
physically changed your brain.